coverage here at noon and let's get you  an update on the latest numbers here in  las vegas  university medical center says it has  seen a big drop in the number of coven  19 admissions that's good news  it is down 73 percent since late july  they've also seen a 90 percent drop in  the number of patients seeking emergency  care for covenant 19  since the peak overall hospitalizations  from covet here in nevada they have  continued on a downward trend  since they peaked in late july and early  august so things are looking good here  but new figures show the coronavirus is  spreading faster in other parts of the  u.s look at this map  at least 29 states are seeing an  increase now in the number of  average cases reported per day five of  them set new one-day records actually  just this past weekend  new york the former epicenter here in  the u.s of the pandemic  reported more than one thousand new  cases a day  for the first time since june